anything that allows you to be 100
close to the end consumer is always the
best
my content if you if you could look at
it one day it's independent
it's more tactical they like to give
them more tools
less motivation yep the details but um
somehow it's it's much easier to push
sex
comedy people want escapism
people want to escape their life they
don't want to make it better
but you think it's very content as a way
of escaping
their life or do you think you're really
educating them
i think i'm tricky because and i don't
know this to be true this is my
hypothesis
and i think there's something very real
about that
you know there is no funnel it's a big
deal
i think that's why i'm winning unlike
almost every other business whether
tactical
or motivational somehow how some way
it's leading to a course to a mastermind
to something that
you know and so i'm giving so purely
that i think subconsciously people
understand that and i think i'm
entertaining
at some level but but we have to be a
little bit of entertainment
i don't think i don't think one has to
be i mean look at you know
i i think there's a lot of people who
are educators and things of that nature
that are not entertaining at all
i don't i don't i think that what you
see the ones that are entertaining
you don't see the ones who are doing 27
million selling a course
quietly nobody knows who they are you
know so i think
the entertaining or the sizzle is in the
face
and people think but like i mean there's
hundreds of thousands of people that
make more money than me
on internet marketing you know because
all they want to do is
the money and you don't even know who
they are they have forty seven thousand
landing pages and they have four hundred
thousand different marketing campaigns
but you know
all depends on what one wants you know
it all depends on what one wants for me
i wanna be the entrepreneur they give
back to the most entrepreneurs
that's what i want
[Music]
i'm always excited when a new platform
comes along that has hundreds of
millions of users
and you can have no following post once
and get a million views yeah that's very
rare
that was 2011 facebook that was
you know this is very rare and and i'm
just fascinated
people's ability yes but but people's
ability to say no
what what frightens people what scares
people
judgment of other people
they don't want to make a tick-tock
video because they're worried about
their friends
and business friends and associates
saying that that's for kids and stupid
and the biggest thing the biggest reason
tick tock matters to somebody who sells
steel
and to 60 year old c-suite executives
in a b2b business is not that tick-tock
even at scale if it got older is
necessarily going to be a platform for
that person to do business
it's that humans are reacting to certain
styles of content
and it's important for you to pick up on
those nuances
it would be no different than when
hip-hop came along
everybody who only believed that rock
and roll was important they said no to
hip-hop they said that's not real music
and then it became the music and so
that's always what happens in popular
culture
the way we storytell on tick tock is
going to matter in 10 years
nowadays the internet is the
distribution
to your point leonardo you know
distribution used to be very expensive
if you wanted to start an actual
television network you had to shoot a
satellite into space
if you wanted to be a newspaper you had
to buy a printing press
and have distribution because the
internet for all of us in this room
is free the reality is that everybody
has the potential to be in the media
business on a personal brand level
on uh talking about your favorite
subject if you want to be the most
important media outlet around
football in the country of mexico
properly executing on top of instagram
properly executing on top of youtube
starting a podcast with no cost
gives you the potential if you're a good
storyteller to be in the game within two
three years
it's crazy how are you my channel
hi guys how are you it is highly likely
highly likely that the breakthrough
or the advancement or the growth that
you're looking for
comes at the expense of you
understanding that you're actually a
media company
and not what else you do i believe that
everybody will realize over the next
decade
that almost everything in our society is
being commoditized
except the ability to communicate that
when you think about what you do
the product you sell and your ability to
communicate it
is fundamentally what's left the
internet
will become the wholesaler the
distributor
the middle
hey guys sorry to interrupt your uh
video i'm just giving you this call for
my number
uh to let you know that you have to join
my text community
uh 212-931-5731 hit me up with a text
what up sir i feel like i know you thank
you man i'm gonna ask you a question yes
i'm in the b2b business yes i'm doing
like you're doing like the whole thing
strategy
ads everything do you still think like
we should still be doing like you know
like trying to keep the content on
landing pages and stuff and so people
leave their email and everything or they
think we should just push everything in
i think a mix is always right but i
think the old
you know content through a google search
strategy is more vulnerable than it was
eight years ago
your strategy that you just laid out is
a google search strategy
and i believe that we've become more of
a content
social network first place so you feel
like
if i'm investing a ton of money into
content i should just push it and
even if i don't get an email or nothing
that's right because brand leads to
opportunity
you know you when you're doing funnels
to landing pages to get leads
you're in the sales business i think you
need to add some marketing
and branding i didn't have the luxury
of living in this world that you guys
live in
there weren't people like me talking
about emotional intelligence around
business
you know this was and so i'm excited you
know when when that young man's like you
really
like when i hear that like you i've been
watching you for three years you really
changed my mindset
it's so powerful it's so powerful i sit
there and when i hear that i'm like man
you know it's funny i'm almost i don't
even feel like i'm myself i'm like
almost watching the conversation and i'm
like wow the world is so crazy
like like we can all you guys already
both feeling it as well and it doesn't
you know and
and so it's just crazy to be able to
impact somebody
you know and i also know what i'm
putting in the system
i'm putting a very important thing into
the system i think selfishly because
i'm winning in business i'm an alpha
male
and most alpha males that are winning in
business
are talking about very different things
that i'm talking about
and i think it's an important balance to
the conversation
leaving money on the table patience
doing the right thing gratitude
empathy like all this stuff that you
know unfortunately for the last 50 years
alpha businessmen were talking about
alpha businessmen stuff but deeply
and secretly were very unhappy and very
broken
and i don't know that's just not
interesting to me i don't want to teach
people how to make a million dollars
but then do drugs and alcohol and be in
depression what's the point
yeah and it's and i'm you know what's
funny i'm very into like
winning and building this is not for me
like
i'm not looking to be a monk or a
or a healing coach or live in that
mountain and have people come and talk
to me about it
i just think it's true i think you can
build a more successful business
if you're actually happy
[Laughter]
you